I mean nothing works 100% of the time
right except Mexicans hi I'm Nick
Gillespie for recent TV and today we're
talking with Ted baliker he's directing
a documentary about raw offensive humor
everywhere under attack that's gonna
come out later this year Ted thanks for
joining us great to be here the name of
your movie can we take a joke okay and
now what we see in contemporary America
is that we really can't Amy Schumer the
Comedy Central comedian just got into
big trouble for suggesting and making
jokes about Mexicans before that Jerry
Seinfeld talked about how hard it is to
go on college campuses because people
are always offended what's going on in
comedy and how how does it affect
freedom of expression well there seems
to be two camps in comedy where you know
if you're funny then that's the only
rule and then there's this other camp
where you have to be funny and you have
to advance all these causes or you have
to avoid certain topics stand-up comedy
or comedy in general does it have a
social function is it you know is it
supposed to make us better people is it
simply is supposed to make us laugh you
know what what I guess what's the best
case for comedy that might be offensive
to some of the people listening to it I
think comedy can be a great icebreaker
to answer your question more directly I
think just to be funny to make other
people laugh is your primary goal now if
you can do other things I guess maybe
that's a higher degree of difficulty and
you get a special prize or something but
comedy is is really the the space it's a
way of broaching topics that were not
quite comfortable about yet so if you
can if you can joke about something it
actually helps open things up one of the
comedians we we have in our film careth
Foster she actually goes to two
universities and does the opposite of
what you see on so many campuses worth
her circu more lists and everybody's
walking on eggshells she tells jokes
about race sex everything and she she
gets the kids to loosen up a little bit
so they loosen up and then they can talk
really openly about these very sensitive
subjects it's that seems to me that I
think the work I think frankly the
university can learn a lot from the
world of stand-up comedians
because the university is supposed to be
this free marketplace of ideas where you
you try different ideas out and test
them against each other you see a lot
more of that frankly in you know Jim
Norton's radio show or you go to Lisa
Lampanelli concert you see people gay
straight black white all kinds and
they're laughing at each other and with
each other and it's really a beautiful
thing you don't see that very often on
college campuses
Ted talked a little bit about what you
call the the outraged mob or the outrage
cycle and it's tied into social media
how how does this work
you know walk us through the steps of a
comedian making a joke and then getting
into trouble and we've all seen it a
million times a comedian tells a joke
someone else gets offended someone else
blogs about it then bloom outrage
spreads across the land and you've
always had an outrage
mob to some degree but what we haven't
always had is modern technology such as
social media and smartphones you can
this days a lot of comedians are
frightened of smartphones because
especially in comedy clubs you're
they're going to it's a work in progress
and you're not like a painter where you
can be by yourself and pay and pay and
pay until you get it right you need the
interaction with the audience and if
someone is there with a smartphone take
something perhaps out of context or
frankly you just remove you you tell a
joke that works in a club and take it
somewhere else it's a completely
different animal and I mean we saw this
I guess with Michael Richards the guy
played Kramer on Seinfeld famously told
some pretty unfunny stand-up comedy
jokes was caught on a smartphone that
gets blogged it gets all over the
internet and he has to make an apology
and even I guess Jerry Seinfeld went on
late-night to help him make apologies
does that is is that a good thing or is
that is that a case of kind of
repressing you know the freedom of
expression I think what's happened is
we've we've really overdone it and Adam
Carolla says in our in our doc you know
making people make phony
I don't know why we viewed this as
progress well we'll leave it there the
movie is can we take a joke and it's
coming out towards the end of the year a
documentary including some of the top
comedians and top most offensive
comedians working working in clubs today
indeed for a reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie